this was one of the biggest volcanic
explosions in history daybreak and Mount
Pinatubo burst
angrily into life again it happened on
June 15th 1991 in the northwest of the
Philippines
it was so powerful it produced a gas
cloud that reached the stratosphere the
explosion caused a lot of damage locally
but the cloud itself did something
extraordinary it lowered the earth's
temperature for four years
sulfur dioxide in the cloud created
particles which spread around the earth
he's then reflected some of the sun's
rays into space scientists are looking
to mimic the effects of this phenomenon
to counter global warming it's a highly
controversial concept known as solar
geoengineering climate change is
probably the biggest problem humanity
faces today in the past 25 years the
global average temperature has risen by
around half four degrees Celsius the
accumulation of carbon in the atmosphere
is warming the earth up making Ortez
hurricanes rains higher temperatures so
far governments have focused on policies
for cutting emissions but they keep
rising the concentration of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere has risen 15%
since 1994 the Paris agreement signed by
175 parties in 2016 was a sign that
countries were willing to work together
to cut emissions
but not every world leader is on board
the Paris climate Accord is simply the
latest example of Washington entering
into an agreement that disadvantages the
United States if emissions aren't
reduced what next
theoretically solar challenge nearing
could cool the entire planet it's
actually potentially incredibly simple
because all you need to do is inject a
bunch of particles into the stratosphere
and there's a number of ways you could
do that recently a study out of Yale and
Harvard looked at the details of how
this would be done in that Harvard and
Yale study they imagined building a
fleet of planes up to 95 of them that
would make 60,000 flights a year the
fleet would spread hundreds of thousands
of tons of sulfur dioxide into the
stratosphere every year after 15 years
they reckon the world would cool by law
point 3 degrees Celsius but there are
reasons not to do this
one of the biggest concerns is that it
could make government's complacent the
big worry is that it will be exploited
to argue against emissions cuts you're
hearing is a supplement to cutting
emissions not a substrate for cutting
emissions it would also be politically
messy if the plan is to put a thermostat
on the earth deciding who has their hand
on the dial won't be easy for it to have
a global effect you're going to need all
governments on board and mine is going
to be extremely difficult if a country
went alone and decided to do it on its
own
then obviously because the impacts are
going to be regional or global you could
create a lot of international tension a
swiss proposal to study geoengineering
and how it should be regulated was
recently put forward at the UN
environment assembly but America and
Saudi Arabia opposed the motion possibly
because they don't want international
regulation of geoengineering as things
stand not enough is known about how it
could impact the climate or the
chemistry of the atmosphere there could
be unexpected consequences you can
affect rain patterns and you might cause
a region that is already suffering from
drought to have even less water a lot
more basic research both into how we
would do it but also what the
consequences would of it would be if we
did it in one way or in another way is
needed but of course if we don't do it
there's deep uncertainty about how much
climate change we get for a given amount
of co2 in the air both of those are
risking both are uncertain the question
is which has the higher risk the
politics of solar geoengineering are so
complex that it might never happen that
said as the world continues to warm the
case for exploring radical measures grow
stronger